people of the internet retro recontour
here and welcome
back to harry potter and the chamber of
secrets we
just finished up our quidditch practice
we learned
expelliarmus and now before we end the
day
i'm gonna run back up to hogwarts and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to try
and gather enough birdy bop beans i want
to hit 100
because that is how many i need for the
alohomora spell
and we've already seen several places
that we can use
this alohomora spell so i think it would
be very useful to know it we just have
to make sure that we have enough
birdie bot beans to buy it all right so
i think the best thing to do might be to
go back to
the defense against the dark arts floor
because there are so many
spots for birdie bop beans there and it
also seems like
they refresh relatively quickly
in the little items that are present on
that floor
so we'll see i mean we'll hop in if we
can yeah if we can get something right
here we might as well
go ahead and try it's at three
[Music]
okay so it takes up to 88 yes it's not
gonna take us
too terribly long to get this oh come on
are you serious
there we go anything
anything anything all right
so yeah if we're at 89 i don't think
we'll have any problem here once we get
to that floor
just double check it right there
one all right fine can we get
10 from the third floor
let's find out it depends on if they've
reset yet or not
because last time it was like they reset
very quickly
yeah here we go
oh come on
there we go three more three more
are you serious how about you how about
you
oh there it is i was about to say dude
if that
i thought that one was going to refuse
to give me just one more
like they intentionally make it harder
the closer you get to 10
or 110 what am i talking about i wish it
was just 10.
all right you know what actually i don't
have to run up there i can just go ahead
and do this right here
and end the day all right time to check
the totals
we should have got at least like 40
points right oh oh
big time big time points for gryffindor
at a solid 200 now up from 80.
hufflepuff jumping all the way up to 153
okay ravenclaw
ravenclaw gonna stop at 189 all right so
they're pretty close to us
let's see where slytherin ends up watch
it be 199.
oh no oh no
slithering ahead by one can't have that
by the way guys if we are meeting for
the first time maybe this is the first
video of mine that you've seen
you should know i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories
they tell i post videos every week here
on
youtube good idea to go to the library
and find a copy of
hogwarts history why do you want it
so we can figure out about the legend of
the chamber of secrets of course
of course i suppose you want me to sneak
out to the library
hermione dude thanks harry the only
thing is you'll need to get to the
restricted section this time
go down to the second floor and just
pass the entrance to the library
there's a portrait that will let you in
the password is
bibliophile right second floor
pass the library portrait got it thanks
harry okay
i will not remember that
second floor past the portrait second
floor past the port let's see does it
show it in my uh
okay good it does floor two
show copy of hogwarts of history to
hermione
on our to-do list at the beginning let's
go in order here number one enter the
library
number two get a copy of hogwarts of
history from the restricted section of
the library
on floor 2. show copy of hogwarts a
history to hermione
alright the other thing we need to do
though is we have got to go
and buy the alohomora spell
like this you can just totally run by
this dude
it cracks me up man let's see look
oh pretty sure that's percy by the way
all right where is it where's alohomora
oh it's right here how much is the aloha
mora spell book
130 votes every flavor beans good thing
i came prepared fred i'd like to buy
that please or george i'm sorry
the alahomora spell allows you to unlock
mechanical locks
let's go all sorts of places you'll be
able to go now
oh yeah all right
chapter nine the key to unlocking
unlock certain doors and chests
mechanical i.e
non-magic folk locks can be troublesome
but not if a witcher wizard knows the
aloha unlocking charm this charm when
cast on certain mechanically locked
doors
will unlock them giving access to the
room or passage
beyond very cool
very cool now exploitable luminous
balloons are a great way to do this well
we don't we don't have any money left
guys
we just bought everything or used
everything rather
[Music]
now you know what the good thing about
that is is when i get hit by enemies
they can't take my birdie bob beans they
can't take them guys
oh wait oh yeah this dude
okay let's go ahead and equip that
though uh i'm gonna put it on
i'll put it where lumos is right now
it's obviously gonna be very situational
all right now let's head on
to the library
oh there come the ghosts haha you can't
take my birdie about beans
i don't have any except now i do
yeah we gotta start collecting again
dude we gotta have enough so we can buy
wizard cards that we don't
uh the ones that we don't end up finding
and also i do need to go ahead and buy
it another one of those potion vials
that can be very useful for sure
is that it okay all right so let's just
go ahead and head straight down there
go to floor two something about past a
portrait i remember her saying
oh jeez
no okay wait a second here girls
bathroom
sorry gotta collect a few beans first
fields won't notice it's all good it's
all good
we're okay we're okay here all right so
what is this one
this is a classroom no okay it's that
room
yeah that door has no purpose whatsoever
unless you slide down okay there
incendio challenge chambers uh
nothing on that one and library annex am
i supposed to just go in the library
annex
and then you find a special portrait
probably so right
back away oh where does this lead man
where does this lead i know i've been
back here before
another door right there we passed two
doors already
oh wait i think this is gonna lead me
dude i hit him come on
i think this puts me out right at the
top
like where gryffindor tower is oh i'm
stuck dude i'm stuck i can't move
i really can't move the game's glitched
i gotta wait for him to get up and hurt
me
are you serious right now are you
serious game
are you look at this look at this
oh now you let me buy
let me see if i'm right on where it
brings me out at
uh oh no i thought it was actually gonna
take me higher okay
it's fine it's fine no
are you serious i just blast that one i
[Music]
thought
all right forget it we're out of here
too many books flying around
i'm just gonna go back down this way
no
i'm running dude they're not even close
to me
come on that is garbage dude
i have to go past the library to find
the portrait to the restricted section
okay past the library so i guess we have
to go through it you know what i'm just
gonna
run that's hilarious that you could just
like
run right by them even when they find
you
i mean it doesn't help that the camera
is just like straight
garbage man it completely reverses
like what you think it should be oh
no no
no
did anyone see him yes
said the portrait nope
where's the portrait
oh that's gotta be it right there right
the portrait bibliophile
hulu file get in there harry yes
dude where's the invisibility cloak when
you need it right
i guess they figured to make it too easy
although they did that in the first game
like and they
they did it very well actually
all right i saw a chest there on my
right is it gonna let me grab it
oh no
all those books
all those flying books to get in our way
and to steal our nine let's see how many
do we have
our ten birdy bot beans man it's not
going to be pretty
but maybe we get a wizard card haven't
it oh come on
i guess we did need a little health too
we did need a little health fine fine
fine
okay a little more health all right
they're one they're wanting to be well
stocked before you uh
attempt this i can tell
all right anything else okay let's go
oh come on harry find the ladder
cracks me up that hermione is like
encouraging
sneaking out after hours
but she's not gonna do it no no no no no
hermione's like i'll send you harry
okay i wonder if i wait for it to fly
out oh yeah because it does not sit
there long at all
i think that one's above me
okay wait for it to pop back out and
go on your merry way
no that's garbage that's totally garbage
that's completely garbage
just like completely or we are playing
harry potter i guess i just say rubbish
it's complete rubbish rubbish i tell you
yeah they're like hey we know you got
hit we know you got hit here have a
cauldron cake
all right up you go hurry dude i need to
remember
in the last time we played where those
alohomora chests were
i want to say it was like in uh there
was one in lockhart's office for sure i
remember that one
yeah just go ahead and take all my beans
i really don't even care at this point
we already got alohomora just take them
all
it's just kind of hard to judge like
like you can't make
incremental movements
i think i'm good right here let that one
go on and fly out
what was that hairy like see
if i go back i'm gonna bump into that
one ridiculous
get up there
come on harry you got this man you got
this we got to be getting close right
why the heck is hogwarts a history
why is it all the way up here isn't that
like one of the basic books that they
need
it totally is
but the game's like uh we'll put the
chamber of secrets in that
and we'll put it in the restricted
section
no no no i didn't mean to do that come
on go go go go go
i don't know why it didn't knock me off
guys
i don't know why but i'm glad it didn't
all right another pumpkin pasty
whoa don't fall off harry
up you go up you go
oh my goodness dude this just went on
for okay i think we're finally there
we just got to make it across this
all right go ahead pop back in
pop back out yeah it doesn't it doesn't
stay in
long enough for you to sneak by all
right go go go go go
okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait okay waiting on the book all right
go go go
yeah we're gonna have to wait for this
one to come back i knew it i knew it
if i was impatient and i kept going that
book was gonna just
bash him right in the head and he would
have fell off
climb up harry what are you doing bro
no just just go dude you got this
i don't know why he falls like when i'm
just standing here okay i did move it
i did move him i admit but before i
wasn't moving him and he just kind of
like randomly slips
oh jeez thank goodness
thank goodness i did not want to have to
do that again i don't
know if you could fall all the way to
the bottom but i did not want to find
out
let me tell you let me tell you
a piece of cauldron cake okay
pumpkin pasty here oh another cauldron
cake okay
fine fine then
all right anything over here
dude they are burying this book way
back in here no one must read about the
history of hogwarts
no one
holy cow look at this man
i did not expect it to open up into a
huge area like this
i just thought i was gonna get to the
top and hey here's the book
i see it already though i see the little
oh no that's a hedwig thing i thought
this was gonna be where the book was
yeah you know what ha you can't take my
birdie by beans
you can't even take them anymore come on
hedwig we need you
hey we need you hedwig
yes all right come on hedwig
can you help us look around hedwig
wait what you're just here you're not
what
you're not gonna help me oh my goodness
hedwig
okay i'm just gonna maybe maybe she
comes into play
here a bit later all right so we got a
doorway there
that is completely blocked over there by
this green
gunk you know what i'm just gonna walk
right up to it and open it
ah she needs a treat that's right
that's right edward hedwig's like i
ain't doing this without a treat
what you talking about come on now
what do i look like to you harry okay
that's locked
so we already called hedwig but now we
just have to
like i'm standing there casting the
spell come on
here you go
all right headwig ladder something for
us to
go up maybe maybe
yes but it's on all the way on the other
side
that's fine though thanks hedwig i just
say we have to cross all these
haunted books again
look at that look at that yeah but
there's more
oh my gosh they're everywhere they're
everywhere just go harry just go
just go they're behind you they're in
front of you they're beside you
okay i have to wall sneak
please don't have any books fly up here
please
please just let us have a nice like
relaxing exploration up here
okay we did need that you guys know
though i still prefer wizard cards
all right fine i know i get it you want
me to be at full health
all right so where
okay we're gonna have to go back across
and i think we're gonna have to run and
jump
over the gap here is what i'm guessing
see there you go nice job harry
i didn't know if you had it in yeah
oh and then we can cast defindo on that
right there
all right so i'm going to switch off
of expelliarmus
all right another pumpkin pasty
and what do we have here
cauldron cake
surprise sky surprise
can we hit it from here
yeah nice
how strong he is guys look how strong he
is
what is with that door man can't go in
there
it's you can't even are they just like
they're definitely look like doors but i
don't see any handles on them
weird
i mean it could just be windows too but
all right oh nicely done nicely done
there's the book right there
edwig's already gone all right probably
some more cauldron cakes and such
in these chests over here
let's see if i'm right come on surprise
me just surprise me
one time surprise me have this last one
be a wizard card
please just do it just do it
they surprised me but not a wizard card
my pockets are nearly full
dude that scared me for a second i
thought he had missed the jump
i thought he had missed that jump
all right here we go
who the heck was that
hogwarts a history by chronicle
chronicles
punnett chapter 13
the chamber of secrets
the legend of the chamber of secrets is
the most enigmatic of all the tales
concerning the establishing of hogwarts
when the four greatest witches and
wizards of their age
godric gryffindor helga hufflepuff
rowena ravenclaw and salazar slytherin
came together to establish a school for
those with magical abilities
it was logical that they chose a
location far away from the eyes of
non-magical people due to the climate of
persecution prevalent at that time
records show that the hogwarts founders
worked together for several years
seeking out youngsters who showed signs
of magic
and bringing them to the castle to be
educated
however a rift grew between slytherin
and the others when he criticized the
number of students being admitted who
came from non-magical families
interesting slytherin believed that
magical learning should be kept within
all magic families and that students of
non-magical parentage were
untrustworthy eventually a serious
argument arose between slytherin and
gryffindor regarding the subject
and such was the acrimony of the
disagreement
slytherin left the school for good the
legend of the chamber of secrets arises
from slytherin's departure and has been
the subject of debate
for many centuries the legend itself
concerns
a chamber supposedly constructed by
slytherin deep beneath the school that
he kept
a secret from the other founders and
sealed so that none would be able to
open it
until his own true heir arrived at the
school
the story goes that would slytherin's
true heir returns
they alone will be able to open the
chamber of secrets and release the
horror within a horror that will purge
the school of those whom slytherin
believed
were unworthy of studying magic
after many extensive searches of
hogwarts over the past
950 years most reputable scholars agree
that the existence of the chamber of
secrets is a fanciful tale concocted by
slytherin supporters
while researching this book the author
consulted the newly appointed headmaster
hogwarts professor albus dumbledore who
stated that during his time at the
school
he had personally seen nothing to
convince him that the legend was based
on
anything other than supposition
well well well
is that so dumbledore
i don't know chat i don't think i buy it
didn't mean to fall like that didn't
mean to fall like that
but i think we're done here anyway i
think
we're done here anyway although i did
want to try
have i been in here yet
no i didn't go in here oh secrets
oh no oh no
wait wait wait what
what excuse me
[Music]
um
oh no
you're a powerful one
oh come on dude
okay
no no no face him face him
like why does it not hit the book i
guess because i'm locked onto him
there you go i was about to say dude
what is going on with this
some random ghosts just decide they want
to mess with harry what the heck
i gotta understand peeves not peeves
though
all right wait do i need to move this i
don't think we have one guardium leviosa
oh we can grab it though
only from this side apparently right
there
right there in that exact spot is where
you can grab it no no no no no
let go let go
like i don't know dude i'm just
expecting that any minute now
in this run we're definitely gonna hear
the basilisk again right
sneaking around at night i just feel
like it's a given that on our way back
to gryffindor tower we're gonna hear it
yet again
okay somebody with a very loud call
don't worry harry i got this dude i'm
just trying to get you in the right spot
to move this box right here you know
magic
you learned when guardium leviosa your
first year you know flopindo
and yet you're having to shove this box
with your bare hands
come on man i know you grew up a muggle
but
well technically you didn't grow up a
muggle but you grew up with muggles
get away from me
oh yeah you better grab that harry like
what is with the camera why does it pull
out like this just keep the camera
behind him for
goodness sake man
blast it oh
my goodness
the pain the pain
i blame the camera dude i do a hundred
percent
100 guys i blame the camera
like why why is it to the side like this
there's no need for it
just just put the camera behind him
put it behind him
okay
oh my goodness thank you i was about to
lose my mind
okay wait i'm gonna wait let the ghost
go by dude that book jumps up there
fast thank you harry
thank you what is this we get another
book here
another spell oh it's gotta be the
scourgify right
gotta be scurgify
yes clears ectoplasm
chapter six cleanliness equal
cleanliness equals wizardliness all
right okay
we'll go with it clear's ectoplasm
ectoplasm is a sticky green substance
left behind by ghosts and has been known
to make doorways
impassable there is a way of cleaning
away ectoplasm without resorting to a
can of
mrs scower's magic mess remover
and this is with an effective scourging
charm such as
scourge okay
all right so do i just like hop back
down now or what
okay that works we've got the we can
weld potion it's okay if we die
all right but i do need to map it let's
put it on
i'll do why
i think it's the only spot in this room
right there
are there are definitely more spots man
like we've been seeing that all over the
castle
in on chests keeping us from opening
chests and things like that
there's also a spot in the library like
in the main section of the library
i actually try and run in there after i
do this
oh look at the bubbles i love it
no don't hit me please get in there
harry get in there
all right nice
okay what's going on in here
oh wow okay i see something behind there
i knew it dude i knew it
i knew it
okay so we are gonna have to do all of
them there's four
panels what would you call that four
bars how on earth do i get out of here
harry just calm down dude we got this
man we got this
even though you may not understand we
we got it all figured out okay just just
relax
oh wow i can't believe i did that
i didn't think they would pull the ghost
thing again though back to back
so now i guess i should just expect it
on every single one of them
another little button to press here
i mean we got to complete it we got to
go ahead and take down all the curtains
back here right
all right two more panels to go
all right this time we ready for the
ghost
where's he at or where's she at yeah see
check it out oh no all the books
come on push it push it push it give me
those eye frames
we have invincibility when we're
pressing the button
i hope so
like i'm spamming it and i couldn't hit
him fast enough
oh no wiggin weld okay
thank goodness it didn't put me back too
far in fact it only put me back to the
beginning of this room
i do not remember using the wigan weld
potion though
i do want to see what's in this chest
even though it's probably yeah i knew it
if i could have gotten there then it
would have filled up my health at least
a little bit
as of now it's not going to do anything
because i should be at max health
all right go ahead let the ghosts fly by
oh we got two on this one there gonna be
another ghost
oh there is oh and i ran right into it
another one another one no okay
all right well that should go ahead and
top me off though oh jeez
[Music]
it goes coming back for more all right
let's open up the door here
[Music]
yo oh he wants to duel
i'm gonna have to put expelliarmus aka
actually protego
see i don't like that man
i if i hold it down
that's ridiculous i guess i just have to
line it up get in front of it
watch this we're going to come back
we're going to come back we're down 5-1
you guys ready for the comeback yep see
there it is told you
yeah take that
i am pressing it dude
oh did it a little too soon there crabby
boy
no way
all right i'll take that trade
garbage garbage time
why doesn't that hit him
how on earth do i get out of here
[Music]
oh i dodged that come on dude oh
got two in a row on him though
nice
dude i pressed it
that is so ridiculous
bye bye bye bye crap go on go go
get on out of here leave me be oh my
gosh is he
wait did we did we
what
hold on hold on what the heck did you do
harry what did you do
he's not moving oh my gosh
his eyes are still open though his eyes
are open
what did you do no
harry how could you with flapindo at
that man
oh my goodness wait where am i supposed
to go okay so we unlock that clearly
that's where they want us to go
but now there's all these other areas
well there's just so those areas that we
already went inside
when we used the scourge spell
all right where are we headed now
okay
all right i get it oh
come on dude grab no nuts
don't stand on it harry grab it
there you go
oh my gosh he can't go he can't go side
to side oh
just enough though perfectly lined up i
don't have to change anything
oh all right no no oh okay
now hop up here there we go harry
you can do this
another ghost no all right
why do you keep saying that harry like
we don't have this under control are you
kidding me right now
oh hit me it's like
harry dude come on you
you can handle this i want earth do i
get out of here
as if it's not obvious potter
all right pindo there and the door's
unlocked
i guess we're just gonna leave crab back
there we're just gonna leave him there
not gonna not gonna notify any
professors or anything
just leave him unconscious in the
wherever we are i already forgot
sneaking back from the restricted
section of the library
all right here we are we have made our
way
there is a portrait i don't know if it's
the same portrait
all right let's pull up the map actually
because i want to see
oh it put me in the library annex
i have no idea oh no this is going to
take me back to the grand staircase
see i don't want to go here though
because oh no go back in
i really want to go to the main part of
the library up here and use
defendo and scourge on those spots
that i haven't tried them on yet so yeah
let's just run on past them
whoa is that hedwig back here
okay so it's up this way now
that thing i don't have anything to do
with that but i do
have something to deal with you
all right let's see what's behind here
okay maybe lumos
maybe lumos maybe
all right then there was no point at all
okay hopefully there's something behind
here though
there we go all right
a ghost ooh chest
wha why would it be that man why would
it be that behind
a hidden door like this
give me the wizard cards oh a treat for
hedwig though
okay there must be a spot that we can uh
call upon hedwig for help in here
there we go that's what we're looking
for
that's what we're looking for right
there number 10
bird dot muldoon 1429 to 1490
burdock muldoon chief of wizards council
from 1448 to 1450.
all right
not very much on him but okay
dude the ghosts are just relentless in
this area
okay well that was actually kind of a
disappointment
because there was nothing at all behind
this door
oh yes chocolate frog but i think
there was that other area that we could
like see into
so i wonder how we actually get in there
let me go up here and check okay another
spot for defendo
ooh a couple different spots yeah we
definitely need to refill this since
apparently i don't remember when i lost
it the last time
[Music]
all right files are now full
there we go that one actually leads us
somewhere
nope nope
[Music]
yes another wizard card
and that should increase our health
right or do we need one more still
purple the fowl ancient
greek he is the first known creator of
the basilisk jk rowling also added in an
interview
that herpo in her mind she she thinks
herpo create
created the first horcrux and i said i
word it that way because
it kind of sounded like she hadn't fully
decided on it yet
but if you guys haven't seen my video
about this when it comes to hogwarts
legacy there is a uh
rumor that herpo the fowl will be
the villain of hogwarts legacy and that
he is actually still alive
because of his horcrux okay so we we
picked up that treat from hedwig
or for hedwig and we still have one more
spot up here that we can cast defendo
on right here
we do not have incendio yet so no point
with that
all right looks like another empty spot
but you know what i'm just gonna
excuse me double check again by using
lumos here
anything special there no okay
all right doesn't hurt to check now
let's see
if there's a spot for me to call hedwig
in here
nope nope nope
interesting so huh
i wonder if it's like behind one of
those other doors
that we just don't have access to yet
because it would be it'd be the same as
it was in that room we were just in
moments ago kind of that little
glowing sparkly area
yeah i don't know interesting all right
well let's go ahead and head back
up to gryffindor tower because i think
we need to yeah
show the book to hermione and she will
advise us from there
all right hermione where are you we've
got the book
and we're ready for you to take a look i
managed to get hogwarts in history but
it wasn't easy
slytherin ambush me crikey can i have a
look at the book harry
here you go
hogwarts was founded over a thousand
years ago slytherin ambushed you
at the age i guess it just means crab
hufflepuff
rowena ravenclaw and salazar slytherin
for a while the four founders worked in
harmony together seeking out
we we read this for money we read it
i moved to bed i'm off to bed i'm
terrified but i'm gonna go to bed guys
later
hermione's just like okay bye oh
man all right well that is going to
conclude this episode guys let's take a
look here
really quick and see yeah end of day is
all we have left so
thank you all so much for watching hope
you enjoyed another episode
of this new let's play series that we're
doing with harry potter and the chamber
of secrets
if you did make sure to give it a thumbs
up as always thank you all so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon